MacPaw — це українська IT-компанія,
яка виробляє власні продукти
програмного забезпечення.
Майже кожен п'ятий користувач Mac так чи інакше
перетинається з якимось із наших продуктів.
На сьогодні у нас уже
понад 30 млн користувачів.
Більшість користувачів —
це все-таки Америка,
це десь 40%.
Майже всі країни Європи —
це також 40%.
Ну і 20% — це вся інша частина світу.
Коли я був студентом,
я намагався майже весь свій вільний час вкласти
в написання коду на створення програми.
І це потребувало дуже значних
зусиль із самого початку.
Витратив рік на написання
коду самого продукту.
Ще десь три чи чотири місяці —
на створення вебсайту.
І потім запуск в публічний
доступ бетареліз.
З цього моменту я вже почав інвестувати
перші кошти в запуск першого офісу,
у наймання перших співробітників.
І ми почали рости як команда.
ІТ-індустрія, напевно, —
це одна з таких індустрій,
яка може одночасно виходити
абсолютно на всі ринки світу.
Тобто коли ми запускали
свій перший продукт,
для нас навіть не було
питання: «Куди йти?».
Ми йшли насамперед до юзерів
[користувачів] Apple,
де вони географічно перебувають.
Спочатку це було, можна сказати,
обмеження англомовних юзерів Apple.
Тобто перша версія не була
локалізована на інші мови.
Тобто всі користувачі, які так чи інакше
користуються англійською мовою,
неважливо, де вони перебувають,
потенційно були нашими користувачами.
Ну, з кожним роком Apple має таку
конференцію на всіх розробників — WWDC.
І щороку там виходили
якісь нові зміни в системі,
якісь нові фічи [особливості],
інновації тощо.
Для нас це завжди був
такий бентежний момент:
«Окей, що цього разу вони
зламають чи зіпсують?».
Один з таких моментів був,
коли Apple фактично випустив
нам прямого конкурента.
Тобто десь п'ять років тому
вони анонсували те,
що тепер в системі буде свій
вбудований CleanMyMac, грубо кажучи.
Для нас це було
спочатку таким шоком.
Думали: «Ну все, тепер юзери будуть
тільки цим користуватися».
Але насправді Apple реалізував досить
такі базові потреби користувачів,
і, можливо, навіть
підсвітив саму проблему,
що дійсно така проблема існує,
навіть Apple намагається
з нею впоратися.
Але якщо є якісь продукти,
які сфокусовані на якісному
вирішенні цієї проблеми,
то вони її можуть вирішувати
набагато краще,
ніж вбудовані в систему
інструменти.
Оскільки основною платформою,
для якої розробляє додатки MacPaw,
є саме платформа MacOS,
еволюція «маків» є стратегічно
важливою для компанії.
На перші комп'ютери Mac неможливо
навіть було встановити будь-які додатки.
Вони навіть не мали екранів.
Але згодом, ви бачите,
як еволюціонував продукт,
еволюціонували платформи.
Тут у нас є колекція
вінтажних iPhone також,
і які зараз «маки»
використовують люди.
Із цікавого, наприклад,
от цей девайс.
Його називають «дідусем iPad»,
тому що він дозволяв
робити те, що, скажімо,
не те, щоб не міг, але було
незручно робити на комп'ютерах.
Ну, у мене було дійсно
багато можливостей переїхати,
і я про це думав
відкрито до 2014 року,
бо тоді я зовсім не бачив
ніяких перспектив.
У нас була, ну відверто,
бандитська влада, на жаль.
Але я побачив після Революції Гідності
дуже велику кількість світлих позитивних людей,
які готові змінювати цю країну.
Я для себе прийняв таку позицію,
що я хочу змінити Україну,
я хочу, щоб наша країна
була успішною.
Я хочу якось через свій вплив,
через свій приклад показувати,
що тут можна створювати
круті продуктові компанії,
що тут можна змінювати
як довкілля, так і міста,
і, можливо, навіть
всю країну зсередини.
«А, ви з України? Ви, напевно,
зв'язані з КДБ, спецслужбами!»
Тобто вкрай часто багато людей не хотіли
мати справу з компаніями з України.
Після 2014 року ситуація
почала змінюватись,
тобто у свідомості, як на мене, багатьох-багатьох
наших зарубіжних користувачів
Україна з'явилась
як такий незалежний суб'єкт,
як країна — не Росія.
І це, як на мене, справило
досить непоганий вплив на те,
що це нас сильно
відділило від Росії.
І, відповідно, користувачі стали більш відкритими
спробувати різні продукти з України.
Багато компаній стали публічними,
зокрема й ми, після 2014 року.
Ми стали публічно говорити,
що ми — компанія з України,
ми пишаємося тим,
що ми перебуваємо тут
і створюємо продукти тут.
Це, можна сказати, змінило сприйняття України
як країни-експортера ІТ-послуг на країну,
яка дійсно може створювати
конкурентні глобальні продукти.
Раніше, щоби продавати
програмні продукти,
це треба було мати таку корпорацію,
яка має свою дистрибуцію,
яка має свої зв'язки.
Зараз це дуже-дуже легко,
і в цьому, як на мене,
ще більший інтерес,
бо це і конкуренція, і плюс завжди є
якісь нові цікаві технології,
якими цікаво користуватися.